et
notre première invitée politique c'est
vous nathalie arthaud bonjour merci
beaucoup d'avoir accepté notre
invitation candidate de lutte ouvrière à
cette élection présidentielle on est
ensemble pendant un peu plus de vingt
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
représenté par christelle bertrand du
groupe la dépêche bonjour cristal temps
chaud oriane bonjour nathalie arthaud
natalia retour vais évidemment parler de
votre programme de votre campagne mais
d'abord un mot sur l'actualité on a vu
les massacres de boudhha on entendu hier
vladimir des lances qui s'exprimait
devant le conseil de sécurité de l'onu
pour y réclamer l'exclusion de la russie
est ce qu'il faut le faire pour vous
tout le monde dit que c'est purement
comment dire
c'est surtout des gesticulations parce
qu'en fait ils ne le peuvent pas et bon
sebha saxons sont effroyables moi je je
pense qu'en effet c'est aussi ça la
guerre dans la guerre c'est je dirais
des chiens de guerre qui sont lancées
contre contre des populations voilà donc
c'est atroce c'est atroce et et moi ce
que ce que je mesure c'est que là il y à
des souffrances terribles avec ses morts
ses destructions ces bombardements
cette terreur qui s'abat sur la
population mais c'est aussi ce fossé de
sang qui est en train de se creuser
entre deux populations
qui étaient entremêlés en fait ce sont
deux peuples frères et ce bain de sang
va donc comment dire créer un un gouffre
un bo et de haine entre voilà
deux peuples et pour combien d'années
pour étayer d'année nathalie arthaud
vous disiez il ya quelques semaines que
vous dénonciez une guerre de brigands
vous disiez que l'otan elle avait fait
de l'ukraine sa marionnette est ce que
vous utiliseriez aujourd'hui les mêmes
mots oui je pense que c'est bladimir
poutine qui mènent aujourd'hui une
guerre monstrueuse et qui est une
première est bien à brigue en a rappelé
que vous opposez à fin mai au même
niveau les uns et des autres je pense
que les uns et les autres ont conduit à
cette situation en effet qui est devenu
d'ailleurs un mythe un maîtrisable ni
par les honnis par les autres voilà je
pense qu'en effet on ne peut absolument
pas s'inscrire dans dans cette
réécriture de l'histoire nous expliquant
que tout ça était arrivé dans un dans un
ciel serein que c'était finalement le le
fait de poutine qui était devenu
complètement dingue ces responsables
seraient aussi responsables je pense que
ce sont les manoeuvres de l'otan de
bayda des puissances impérialistes dans
toute cette région qui ont en effet mis
l'ukraine
au centre au centre d'un bras de fer qui
dépasse largement zelensky d'ailleurs à
et qui dépasse bien sûr la population
ukrainienne mais vous savez quand même
il faut faut bien réaliser que l'otan
l'otan ce n'est pas une agence de paix
l'otan ça a été une alliance militaire
qui a été créé au moment de la guerre
froide contre l'union soviétique pour
l'isoler pour l'affaiblir quand l'union
soviétique s'est disloqué en 91 pourquoi
l'otan n'a t elle pas été dissoute
pourquoi non seulement elle n'a pas été
dissoute mais elle a multiplié les bases
militaires à la frontière de la russie y
compris les etats-unis ont envoyé un
certain nombre de soldats entraînés les
l'armée ukrainienne donc c'est cette
presse locale fait aujourd'hui ne
démontre pas l'utilité de l'otan puisque
l'ukraine est attaquée parce qu'elle
n'est pas membre de l'otan et les autres
pays ne sont pas parce qu'ils sont
membres de l'eau mais justement voyez
c'est un petit jeu très cynique
finalement de la part de la part de
l'otan et de la part des américains
c'est à dire que à la fois ils ont
utilisé en effet l'ukraine pour pousser
leurs pions pour gagner en influence
dans toute cette région à poser aussi
leurs intérêts économiques dans toute
cette région mais aujourd'hui que
poutine a décidé d'aller à
l'affrontement armé ils font très
attention
un bain de finalement ne pas être dans
un dans un affrontement qui les
pousserait
y compris plus loin qui aurait peut-être
d'autres conséquences et c'est donc moi
c'est séance et en cela d'ailleurs que
je pense qu'ils sont capables en effet
d'utiliser des peuples comme des comme
des marionnettes vous feriez vous
aujourd'hui pour sortir de ce conflit à
moi aujourd'hui si j'avais mois plus de
plus de pouvoirs et de possibilités la
première des choses je pensais que je
m'adresserai au peuple russe on a
beaucoup dit les experts eux mêmes
explique l'armée russe et
bringuebalante que finalement un certain
nombre de soldats sont dans ses rivaux
d'hier coin comment et comment surtout
donc je continue certains soldats russes
sont embarqués ont roulé dans cette
guerre ils sont envoyés dans des coins
ils ne savent pas où ils savent pas
pourquoi pour quel type de guerre et
caetera et qui a quand même beaucoup de
comment dire d'hésitations et de manque
de détermination incertain explique
d'ailleurs comme ça l'échec finalement
de l'avancée de l'armée russe donc ça
veut dire qu'on doit pouvoir en effet
s'appuyer sur le
le rejet de cette guerre par la
population russe au feuilleton great
food en réalité arrêt vous faire tomber
poutine bien sûr pour faire ton bouton b
poutine pour le renverser pour renverser
cette dictature qui en réalité fait
souffrir les ukrainiens mais beaucoup
aussi la population russe un mot sur ce
qui se passe au sahel où les soldats de
l'opération barkan soit toujours présent
même si un redéploiement et un retrait
progressif est ce que vous si vous
arrivez à l'elysée vous retirer
immédiatement les troupes françaises du
sahel où partent du sahel et de
l'afrique du sahel et du continent
africain parce que on dit oui tout de
suite tout de suite oui d'abord on voit
qu'ils sont rejetés par la population du
mali elle même un donc ça c'est quand
même le fruit voyez d'un échec
incroyable hein quand françois hollande
a
on sait les troupes en expliquant qu'il
allait sauver et finalement les maliens
qu'ils étaient appelés comme des
bienfaiteurs et cetera que ça allait
durer quoi une semaine quinze jours et
sait où on en est aujourd'hui où on en
est aujourd'hui un cdd de qu'on aurait
pas vilain les huit maires servir bien
sûr elle n'aurait pas dû y aller bien
enfin que bien sûr que parce qu'à chaque
fois finalement un clar mais française
est lancée sur ces théâtrale à
d'opérations extérieures ce n'est jamais
jamais pour répondre aux besoins de la
population et sa mère va travaux dans la
lutte fait environ pour vous la preuve
où en est on est ce que le terrorisme a
reculé dans la région en fait il s'est
disséminé en fait les bandes djihadistes
alors qu'ils se mélangent d'ailleurs un
avec des bandes de là en l'occurrence de
brigands des bandes armées enfin bon
tout ça c'est un un mélange et bien
elles se sont étendues on parle
maintenant que le burkina faso et à est
également concerné donc vous voyez qu'en
réalité ça a été une diffusion et il
faut bien comprendre que ces bandes
djihadistes que ce terrorisme il est
alimenté par quoi d'abord et avant tout
par le dénuement part par la misère par
la dislocation des états par will le
fait que justement c'est c'est le
dénuement total donc dès qu'on a une
arme dans cette région là dès qu'on peut
enrôler un certain nombre de deux
soldats et bien on a du pouvoir et on a
envie mieux voilà voilà la réalité de la
situation alors combattre sa part les
armes et bien regardez ça mène à cet
échec qu'on connaît aujourd'hui et vous
savez depuis le temps que la france et
en afrique parce que c'est pas une
présence tout à fait nouvelle 1 avec la
colonisation
depuis le début depuis le début la
france est allée en afrique on va
apporter la civilisation à bâle est
belle elle est belle la civilisation
apportées par la france autre sujet
d'actualité c'est en pea le gouvernement
a rendu public hier
le rapport qu'il avait commandé sur la
gestion des ehpad du groupe orpea c'est
un rapport accablant avec de la
nourriture insuffisante pour les
résidentes priorité qui est donnée à la
performance financière qu'est ce que
vous pensez de ce rapport et que ferez
vous pour éviter de nouvelles dérives
d'abord vous aurez peut-être remarqué
que le rapport n'est pas rendue publique
dans son intégralité en nous cachent
encore des chiffres et au nom de quoi un
de dieu secret le second vote après vous
et les îles cash mais c'est pas là vous
cache c'est que dans le rapport il tous
les chiffres commerciaux sont biffés
voilà on peut pas les avoir on ne pas
les avoir au nom de la concurrence mais
enfin moi je me dis mais dans quelle
société vit-on il ya une affaire de
concurrence une affaire effectivement de
rivalité financière sur cette tendance
dans ce secteur là mais moi je trouve ça
dingue c'est vraiment vous savez le
limon oulémas de france à celle des
affaires alors je veux mettre fin au
secret des affaires je pense qu'il
devrait pas y avoir de recherche de
profits dans ce domaine là comme dans le
domaine de la santé je pense également
que là on a un rapport ministériel
bon très bien on a eu 1 une enquête de
deux journalistes donc de victor
castanet qui était effectivement très
complète mais ça fait quand même des
années que le personnel des ehpad
témoigne sous anonymat sous anonymat
combien y at il une enquête envoyés
spéciaux enfin voilà et finalement il y
à une omerta c'est ça la réalité et moi
c'est ce que je dénonce dans toutes les
entreprises flics et sept au maire clark
dans toutes les entreprises je dénonce
ça je dénonce qu'on n'entend pas la voix
des salariés ça voilà on ne veut pas
leur donner la parole et à chaque fois
d'ailleurs on essaye de les faire taire
de les faire taire parce que menacés de
licenciement parce qu'ils auraient violé
le secret professionnel et de les faire
pour moi je mets pour cacher précisément
ces méfaits pour cacher ses méfaits pour
cacher même ses crimes en réalité vous
savez il y a les profits ces sables et
ont réservé les profits mais bien sûr
pour préserver les caisses alors qu'est
ce que vous faites qu'est ce que vous
faites et nathalie arthaud si vous êtes
élu qu'est ce qu'on fait sur la gestion
de ces ehpad est ce que vous mettez
faisaient pas de prime c'est la même
question vous savez sur buitoni du
taudis ou des salariés avaient dénoncé
que finalement la propreté n'était pas
faite que sur certaines installations il
y avait des signes de moisissures et
maintenant on en est avec combien
d'enfants qui sont dans le coma alors
qu'est ce que vous proposez sur le jeu
et propose et bien l'abolition du secret
des affaires et qu'on donne cette
possibilité là aux salariés de dénoncer
les méfaits dont ils sont témoins ou les
infractions les délits ce qui devrait
être fait ce qui n'est pas fait donc
qu'on leur donne en fait cette
possibilité là sans qu'ils risquent leur
boulot sans qu'ils pouvaient dès lors
derrière multiplient les contrôles aussi
nombreux qu'on ne le résoudrons pas
multiplier les contrôles il faut arrêter
avec ça qu'est ce qu'on fait à paroles
nova à rien une fois que la la division
générale qu'est ce que ça veut dire
attendons leur baloune à sanary la dg
c'est la dgccrf qui est censé faire ces
contrôles faire ces enquêtes a souligné
qu'elle n'avait plus les moyens parce
qu'il y avait eu tellement de
suppressions d'emplois plus tellement de
suppressions d'emplois qu'il n'avait
plus les moyens de mener ses enquêtes
appuyons nous sur ce qu'ils savent
appuyons nous sur les salariés moi je
dis donnons la possibilité aux salariés
de mettre sur la place publique ce dont
ils sont témoins mais enfin quand même
rien du maire doit faire les commissions
narration une fois que ça sur la place
publique on en fait quoi ben on en fait
quoi eh bien on interdit on on mène
procès écouter on en fait quoi vous vous
prenez votre voiture vous vrai à 52 km
vous avez une amende qui tombe bon mais
quand on voit des des méfaits et des
délits comme ça dans les entreprises
pourquoi une amende ne tomberai tel
pourquoi ignorer qu'il n'y aurait-il pas
de la prison pour ce qu'ils ont décidé
pourquoi dites moi pourquoi pourquoi on
est capable nouveaux pauvres de nous
contrôler dans nos actions quotidiennes
à partir du moment où on a les preuves
on a les témoignages et bien évidemment
on sanctionne ont contraint ont puni on
va parler de pouvoir d'achat à votre
programme l'une des revendications
principales des français portent sur le
pouvoir d'achat principalement depuis la
guerre en ukraine vous vous proposez de
supprimer la tva de supprimer l'impôt
sur le revenu j'ai envie de demander
avec quel argent du coup on paye ton les
professeurs les soignants et puis les
gens passent alors vous voyez que
pourquoi aussi cette revendication de
l'abolition de secret des affaires qui
permettrait précisément de voir tout
l'argent qu'il y a dans dont ces
multinationales dans ces grandes
entreprises tous les profits tout
l'argent qui va bien à quel public cela
aux hôpitaux publics non mais en
l'occurrence on verrait justement
l'argent disponible à l'échelle de toute
la société pas seulement dans les
caisses de l'état mais à l'échelle de
toute la société vous savez rien que les
160 milliards de profits qui sont
annoncés par les 40 premières
entreprises cotées en bourse le cac40
160 milliards 160 milliards ces quatre
millions d'emplois payer à 2000 euros
nets dans cotisations inclus etc ces
quatre millions d'emplois vous rendez
compte donc il ya de quoi faire il ya de
quoi faire donc moi je pense en effet
que si on avait cette volonté là cette
volonté là de dire priorité aux emplois
priorité aux salaires eh bien on
pourrait faire quelque chose de très
simple on pourrait appeler les
enseignants moi je me vois tout à fait
un avec mes collègues
unir veut réunir pour dire voilà les
emplois dont on a besoin voilà comment
on devrait fonctionner 24 élèves par
classe pas plus donc voilà combien il
faut de d'enseignants en anglais en
mathématiques etc combien il faut aussi
d'encadrants combien combien il faut
des 2
dead aussi pour accompagner les enfants
en situation de handicap on est tout à
fait capable de faire la liste est de
dire les emplois à créer et ça de le
faire pas seulement dans l'éducation
dans les hôpitaux aussi faire un amour
les hôpitaux dans les ehpad et là je
peux vous dire qu'on aurait des emplois
créés et bien sûr qu'on augmente les
salaires on doit prendre est justement
un mot sur le smic ce que vous voulez un
smic m à 2000 euros c'est beaucoup plus
que les autres candidats c'est le
maximum est ce que c'est vraiment une
app pour les petites et moyennes
entreprises sur l'on vaut d'abord
pourquoi pourquoi 2000 euros net c'est
parce que moi précisément je ne pars pas
de l'idée 1 qu'est ce qui pourrait être
réalisable réaliste du point de vue
aujourd'hui de grand patronat parce que
clairement de son point de vue dès qu'on
revendique de toute façon il n'y a rien
de possible il n'y a rien de réaliste la
seule chose qui est réaliste c'est qu'un
bernard arnault par exemple lui en
caisse de smic à la minute ça c'est
réaliste c'est d'ailleurs ce qui se
passe selon les tpe et les pme donc moi
ce que je veux je pars simplement de ce
qui est nécessaire pour vivre et ce qui
est nécessaire pour vivre sans être dans
l'angoissé permanente sont se dire
qu'est ce qui va s'exercer showroom à la
lune entre ces deux ans et plus d'1 2
euros qu'elle n'en gagne donc est ce
qu'elle peut payer des salariés à ce
niveau là dans certaines circonstances
peut être que c'est plus friands des
groupes que pour dpm oui c'est peut-être
plus facile pour les grands groupes mais
figurez vous même ces grands groupes là
ils ne le font pas mais qu'est ce que
j'ai dit aux petits patrons sont
maintenant moi ce que je dis là ils font
ce que je dis aux travailleurs c'est
qu'une on ne doit pas se laisser comment
dire
paralysée toujours en prenant l'exemple
de la petite entreprise en difficulté
d'abord je tiens à dire parler
d'entreprises en difficulté sur les
petites et moyennes entre le garçon
ils ont des salaires à s'entendre de
petites entreprises peux vous dire
qu'ils payent des salaires au delà de
2000 euros à leurs ouvriers à leurs
salariés qui sont souvent qualifiés
aussi donc bien souvent elles vont au
delà parce que les bas salaires s'est
pas réservé aux petites entreprises
c'est aussi chez carrefour c'est aussi à
michelin c'est aussi à peugeot c'est
aussi dans ces tentes dans toutes ces
grandes entreprises c'est aussi dans la
fonction publique grandes entreprises
s'il en est un dans les hôpitaux dans
dans les écoles à la poste c'est des
très très petit salaire donc moi je
pense qu'ils vous pareil pour les
collectivités vous dites aux
collectivités territoriales de ces
nouveaux agents 2009 en a mais bien sûr
alors muscles avec des dotations de
vector unit des entreprises les petites
entreprises qui seraient en difficulté
il faut comprendre aussi pourquoi elles
sont en difficulté 1 est ce que ce sont
les banques qui se gavent sur les
petites secondes prises oui souvent très
souvent très souvent ce sont les
donneurs d'ordre qui les étrangle alors
encore une fois on doit organiser et
avoir cet objectif là d'organiser la
société d'abord pour qu'elles répondent
aux besoins de ceux qui la portent de
ceux qui la font tourner donc d'abord
les besoins en effet des salariés 2 deux
de ceux qui font le boulot de ceux qui
sont à la base de tout moi je suis
scandale orpea combien peuvent-ils leur
aide soignant à orpéa 1 orpea bas on en
a vu justement ce micmac eh bien ils
sont pas à 2000 euros nets et bien moi
je vois là ça doit être notre combat
notre perspective c'est justement sur la
santé l'occupation des français
également oui j'ai rien trouvé dans
votre programme sur la lutte contre les
déserts médicaux qui est une des
préoccupations principales des français
on sait qu'aujourd'hui dans certains
endroits de province il est très
compliqué de se soigner que proposez
vous vous n'avez rien de trouver parce
que vous n'avez rien trop parce qu'on ne
fait pas de catalogue de promesses
électorales mais ce que nous défendons
est ce que nous portons pour la la la
médecine c'est très clair depuis depuis
fort longtemps nous nous sommes contre
le numerus clausus de pensons qu'il faut
former beaucoup plus de médecins qu'il
faut les former et pas dans ces
formations qu'on connaît aujourd'hui un
où c'est marcel et enfin au numerus
clausus pardon il a été mis fin au
numerus clausus aux gens mais bien trop
tard et encore encore que il manque des
places dans les écoles d'infirmières
moi je peux vous dire que j'ai des
élèves qui sont bloqués qui voudraient
aller sur ces vocations là et qui ne le
peuvent pas donc il faudrait ouvrir
démultiplier les places déjà donc formé
plus de médecins et puis en effet allés
sur la création de maisons de santé un
certain nombre de structures qui sont
très demandés par des médecins qui ne
veulent plus travailler tout seul et on
les comprend donc il faudrait en effet
débloquer un certain nombre de moyens
les obliger les médecins à obliger les
médecins à aller dans cette déserts
médicaux pas au bout d'être contre
obligation je pense que si on crée
beaucoup beaucoup de
deux places de mes 2 comment dire de
maison médicale peut-être que d'un
centième de choses pourraient pourrait
être régulée par l'envi plus que par la
contrainte d'une part leur vie mais bon
après on peut aussi concevoir qui est
une meilleure répartition vous et moi je
suis enseignante je suis allé travailler
là où il y avait besoin donc on peut
aussi concevoir c'est quelque chose que
moi j'imagine aussi pourquoi pas pour la
santé sur l'environnement nathalie
arthaud lo j acques a publié un énième
rapport hier
votre programme a été pointé du doigt
notamment par greenpeace qui trouve que
vos propositions sont légères en la
matière vous ne croyez pas au
réchauffement climatique ou
ouais ça me fait toujours sourire
solution pendant cette campagne je peux
vous dire que ça va beaucoup beaucoup
fait sourire à ces associations qui
regardent et voilà les catalogues la
électoraux et puis qui jugent et de
comment dire du degré de verdissement et
c'est en fonction de ça ça me fait rire
parce que parce qu'on ne faut pas les
croire parce qu'il ne faut pas les
croire ils ont tous des très très beau
pourquoi mais parce que toutes les
promesses électorales elles finissent à
la poubelle vous le savez autant que moi
donc goûter féret nouvelle macro mais là
non je préfère pas faire de promesses en
effet et je préfère expliquer d'où vient
que oublier ce que vous pensez du
réchauffement climatique aujourd'hui je
pense que c'est un drame mais comme tout
le monde je pense qu on court à la
catastrophe mais je pense que c'est tout
le système économique qui nous pinky
nous qui nous pousse dans le précipice
je pense que si on fait rien contre ces
multinationales si on les laisse faire
et ce qui comme elles veulent je les
viandes on est qu'il faut faire au jour
donné je suis contre le réchauffement
climatique est ce qu'il faut faire il
faut imposer des contraintes et il faut
absolument interdire
à ces multinationales de décider tout
seul dans leur coin il faut moi je suis
pour l'expropriation d arcelormittal des
grands groupes chimiques industriels des
grands groupes bancaires des grands
groupes énergétiques je suis pourquoi
les fusionne et pour qu'on décide selon
un plan
démocratiquement arrêté à au travers
d'une planification démocratique on
décide de coke est ce qu'on produit
comment on le produit c'est comme cela
qu'on pourra enfin gérer véritablement
notre système productif aujourd'hui
qu'est ce que c'est c'est les lois du
marché c'est les lois de l'offre et la
demande c'est un gaspillage inouïe et
tout ça pour quoi pour que ces messieurs
puissent réaliser leur taux de profit
deux enterrés aujourd'hui qu'il faut
produire moins je pense qu'il ya des
choses qu'il faut produire moi moi je
pense qu'il faut produire moins du yacht
- des hôtes il faut produire moins
d'engins - domicile - de chars de combat
moins d'avions rafale je pense qu'il
faut produire moi voilà pour les
caprices des riches et je pense qu'il
faut donc produire plus de logements je
pas accessible à salé un moyen je pense
que voilà il faut développer l'éducation
les soins etc etc et ça je pense que si
on me demandait la réunion répond
clairement ce serait il nous reste trois
petites minutes pour parler de la
campagne j'ai c'est votre troisième
campagne natale et à tous et une combine
particulière pour vous la vivez comment
différemment des autres je crois que
c'est une campagne qui est empreinte de
plus de gravité parce que l ai ressenti
par
par la population écoutez ces
difficultés pour vivre pour boucler les
fins de mois face à cette flambée des
prix cette
l'avenir on nous explique l'inflation
elle va s'installer que ça sera plus dur
qu'il faudra moins chauffer qu'il faudra
faire encore des sacrifices avec cette
guerre etc etc la menace climatique la
menace climatique mais tout ça est lié
et vous savez je crois qu'il ya ce
sentiment vraiment cette interrogation
profonde de femmes et d'hommes qui 6
mais où va-t-on et cette conscience que
ça dépend pas du président de la
république c'est un problème beaucoup
plus vaste que c'est lié en effet un
système qui marche sur la tête parce
qu'il n'est pas organisé précisément
pour répondre et élire soins aujourd'hui
vous présenter comme le parti des
travailleurs une grande partie des
travailleurs vont voter
vraisemblablement dimanche pour marine
le pen c'est en tous les cas ce que nous
disent les sondages comment vous
l'expliquez en quoi vous avez échoué à
les convaincre non ce n'est pas moi qui
ait échoué la plupart des électeurs
ouvriers des classes populaires qui
iront voter pour le pen voter pour qui
avant pour le parti socialiste ou pour
le parti communiste donc s'il ya un
échec il est à regarder du côté de leur
politique passée le moral avec de belles
promesses vous norbu me reprocher ne pas
faire de belles promesses mais moi ce
que je reproche c'est que la gauche au
pouvoir elle n'a jamais tenu ses
promesses elle n'a jamais tenu ses
promesses et à la c'est les travailleurs
dans la galère aujourd'hui on est face à
une situation de désorientation
politiques dans le monde du travail oui
la plupart des ouvriers bas
s'abstiennent des précaires
s'abstiennent ou y compris les autres et
bien de leur vie moi j'ai envie de leur
dire que en effet on peut changer les
choses nous pouvons nous défendre nous
pouvons même remettre cette société sur
ses pieds mais ça dépend de nos luttes
collectives de notre conscience
collective ça dépend de notre capacité à
nous organiser donc moi mon ma
candidature est clairement un appel au
rassemblement
un appel à la conscience que les
travailleurs font tout dans cette
société mais ils peuvent ils peuvent
défendre ils peuvent se battre pour
leurs intérêts et c'est en se battant
pour leur intérêt pour leurs intérêts
élémentaire que oui on combattra cette
course aux profits on combattra cette
société
produit par dont ils ont peur d'aller
voter marine le pen lisons d'or ils ont
tort de voter le pen mais ils ont tort
aussi de voter macron ils ont tort de
voter pour des politiciens
professionnels villes asiatiques qui
avaient été les biens sur le même
donnerait pas de consigne de vote je
pense que clairement il faut qu'ils
votent pour l'heure quand il faut mais
je suis sans mots et aux je vais
attendre le deuxième tour pour savoir ce
qui va se passer mais clairement au
premier tour je pense que vers un vote
de conscience un vote de fierté ouvrière
dire bah finalement fait tout fonctionné
eh bien nous on se battra pour que la
société elle change merci nathalie
arthaud merci bonjour merci ben ammar
était notre invité ce matin
[Musique]